well Siobhan joins us now live from
Marseille and our correspondent Tom
palminter is not far from me here in
Paris Tom to you first of all what is
the situation where you are down near uh
the Arthur Triumph
well there's hundreds upon hundreds of
riot police officers on the streets
tonight some 45 000 across France but
here in the capital it's very tense
indeed on the seanice if we just walk
down a little bit you can see the lines
of police that have been moving up and
down they had hundreds upon hundreds of
young people predominantly who were
gathered along the Sean's Elysee there
was a lot of talk earlier today that
this is where they would congregate to
create disorder and the police are here
in massive numbers we've seen officers
there just walking along with tear gas
canisters primed and ready to be
deployed if they choose to also officers
with non-lethal Firearms here uh it is a
very uneasy atmosphere as we've seen
across France in so many Urban centers
but here in Paris tonight it does feel
very tense 37 arrests so far just on the
champs-elysees of course one of the most
famous shopping streets in the world and
the police have been sharing images of
things they've been confiscating from
people who have been congregating down
here tonight and that includes petrol
bombs includes knuckle dusters and a
catapult that the police have seized and
the officers that we've been speaking to
on the ground have described the
situation as electric and they just
don't know where the trouble will come
but they are very confident that it will
come and you can see them moving down
along the champs-elysees with us live
here on Sky News tonight and it is a
very fluid situation no major disorder
from what we've seen so far in Paris
tonight but it is a very tense situation
and the pattern and the cycle of
violence that we've seen over the last
four nights it seems almost inevitable
here that that will continue
[Music]
okay Tom thanks very much for that let's
return to Siobhan who is in Marseille
and there has been a certain amount of
disturbance there already this evening
hasn't there Siobhan and it is a
slightly different demographic in
Marseille as well what is the latest
yes so in the last half an hour or so
we've seen a real uptick in the amount
of tear gas being used by the police the
tactic here essentially seems to be that
they fire in a load of tear gas the
protesters run up the street they
regroup they do it again and every time
they're hoping fewer and fewer people
basically are taking part in these
protests now if you can see the lights
down the back behind me I've just moved
a bit further down the street just to
talk to you because there has been a
little bit of hostility towards
certainly one journalist today we saw
someone being beaten up so we've just
moved away now but where those lights
are is basically the front line of the
police it's on an intersection and then
so the protesters are coming up and down
the kinds of things we've been seeing
going on today no no particular looting
which is what the police have been
trying to avoid instead we've seen bins
being set on fire protesters smashing up
a tram stop we've seen also them pulling
um out signs as well but the police
really seem to be on top of this tonight
I was told by someone who was here last
night that they believe there's about
double the amount of police here and
we've seen some quite high-level police
units here as well so they've sent in a
unit for example that's often used to
negotiate with people who've taken
victims and kidnapped victims so very
high level police but at the moment from
where I'm standing it seems like the
police seem to be winning this battle
tonight they definitely seem to be
dispersing those protesters and what we
aren't seeing is the scenes that were
happening here last night which was many
shops being smashed up being looted and
essentially what shop owners were saying
was protesters looters running a mock in
this city with very little pushback it
seemed like from shop owner's point of
view they weren't being under control
but tonight a very different scene and
as I was saying from my point of view it
seems at the moment the police are
winning this fight but it is a very
fluid situation